o la vida de mi familia?
Los problemas de salud cuando no hay sistemas de salud
también son aterradores.
Solía escuchar a muchas familias hacerse preguntas del tipo,
"Mi niño tiene fiebre. ¿Qué voy a hacer?"
"Mi hermana, que está embarazada, está sangrando. ¿Qué debo hacer?
¿A quién debo acudir?
"¿Dónde están los médicos y las enfermeras?
Si encuentro uno, ¿cómo sé si son merecedores de confianza?
¿Cómo les voy a pagar? ¿Con qué moneda les voy a pagar?"
"Si necesito medicamentos, ¿dónde los encuentro?
¿Y si tomo esos medicamentos y en realidad son equivocados?
Y así sucesivamente.
Entonces, al vivir en este contexto,
el tema principal, la característica principal de la vida
es la extrema vulnerabilidad en la que las personas viven
día a día,
por la falta de sistemas sociales.
Y, de hecho, resulta
que esta característica de la vida es sumamente difícil de explicar
y de ser comprendida por aquellos que no la viven.
Me di cuenta de esto cuando me fui de Kosovo.
Volví a Boston, me convertí en médica,
me convertí en investigadora de políticas sanitarias públicas mundiales.
Ingresé en la Facultad de Medicina de
Harvard y a la División Salud Mundial del Brigham and Women.
Como investigadora,
lo que realmente quería era resolver este problema.
Pensaba, "¿Cómo reducir la vulnerabilidad devastadora
de las personas que viven en este tipo de situaciones delicadas?
¿De qué manera podemos comenzar a pensar sobre
cómo proteger y recuperar rápidamente
a las instituciones que son esenciales para la subsistencia,
como el sistema de salud?"
Y debo decir que he tenido colegas increíbles.
Pero lo que me resultó interesante fue
que esta era una pregunta inusual para ellos.
Decían, "Ah, si trabajas en la guerra, entonces
significa que trabajas en campos de refugiados,
y documentas atrocidades masivas, ¿no? -
lo cual, de hecho, es muy pero muy importante.
Me llevó un tiempo explicar por qué me apasionaba tanto este asunto,
hasta hace casi seis años.
Allí fue cuando este estudio histórico
que atendía y describía las consecuencias de la guerra en cuanto a la salud pública
fue publicado.
Llegaron a una conclusión increíble y provocativa.
Estos investigadores concluyeron
que la mayoría de las muertes y discapacidades ocasionadas por la guerra
suceden luego de finalizado el conflicto.
Por eso, la época más peligrosa para vivir en un estado afectado por el conflicto
es tras el cese de las hostilidades;
es luego de la firma del tratado de paz.
Es cuando se ha logrado dicha solución política.
Eso suena muy desconcertante, pero definitivamente no lo es,
porque las guerras matan a las personas al privarlas de sus clínicas,
de sus hospitales,
de sus sistemas de suministro.
Los médicos se convierten en el blanco, son asesinados; huyen.
Y más invisible, e incluso más mortal es la destrucción
de las instituciones de gobernanza de salud y de sus finanzas.
Entonces esto no me sorprende en lo más mínimo.
Pero lo que sí me sorprende y me preocupa
es el poco impacto que ha tenido esta introspección,
en cuanto a cómo pensamos sobre el sufrimiento humano y la guerra.
Déjenme darles un par de ejemplos.
El año pasado, quizás se acuerden,
el Ébola alcanzó a Liberia, país del África occidental.
Hubo muchos reportajes sobre este grupo, Médicos Sin Fronteras,
que daban la alarma y solicitaban ayuda.
Pero casi ninguno de los reportajes contestaba la pregunta:
¿Por qué motivo está Médicos Sin Fronteras en Liberia?
Médicos Sin Fronteras es una organización increíble,
dedicada y diseñada para proporcionar cuidado de emergencia en zonas de guerra.
La guerra civil en Liberia había terminado en el 2003,
11 años antes de que el Ébola afectara al país.
Cuando el Ébola atacó en Liberia,
habían menos de 50 médicos en todo el país
de 4,5 millones de personas.
Médicos Sin Fronteras se encuentra en Liberia
porque Liberia aún no tiene un sistema de salud en funcionamiento,
11 años más tarde.
Cuando el terremoto azotó Haití en 2010,
la efusión de ayuda internacional fue impresionante.
Pero, ¿sabían que solo el 2% de los fondos
fueron para reconstruir las instituciones públicas de Hatí,
incluso el sector sanitario?
Desde ese punto de vista,
los haitianos siguen muriendo a causa del terremoto incluso hoy en día.
Hace poco conocí a este hombre.
Este es el Dr. Nezar Ismet.
Es el Ministro de Salud de la región autónoma del norte de Iraq,
en Kurdistán.
Está aquí para anunciar que en los últimos nueve meses,
su país, su región, ha aumentado de cuatro millones de personas
a cinco millones de personas.
Eso es un aumento del 25 %.
Miles de estos recién llegados han sufrido grandes traumas.
Sus médicos trabajan 16 horas por día sin percibir sueldo.
Su presupuesto no ha aumentado un 25 %:
ha disminuido un 20 %,
ya que los fondos se han invertido en temas de seguridad y ayuda a corto plazo.
Cuando su sector sanitario falla,
y como demuestra la historia, sucederá,
¿cómo creen que afectará
la toma de decisiones de cinco millones de personas en su región
porque piensan si deberían huir
de estas condiciones de vida vulnerables?
Como pueden ver, este es un tema frustrante para mí,
y de verdad trato de entender:
¿Por qué la reticencia a proteger y apoyar
sistemas de salud y seguridad autóctonas?
Generalmente, tengo dos preocupaciones, dos argumentos.
La primera preocupación es la corrupción,
las personas en estos contextos son corruptas
y poco fiables.
Y admito que he conocido personajes desagradables
trabajando en ámbitos de salud en estos contextos.
Pero les diré que lo contrario es completamente cierto
en todos los casos en los que trabajé,
desde Afganistán a Libia, Kosovo, Haití, Liberia --
he conocido personas inspiradoras,
quienes, cuando a su país le llegó la hora,
arriesgaron todo para salvar las instituciones de salud.
La clave para aquellos terceros que quieren ayudar
está en identificar quiénes son esos individuos,
y en construir un camino para que ellos lideren.
Esto es exactamente lo que sucedió en Afganistán.
Una de las historias de éxito olvidadas y nunca contadas
de nuestro esfuerzo por construir una nación en Afganistán
implicaba una gran inversión del Banco Mundial en 2002
para identificar, capacitar y promover a líderes afganos del sector sanitario.
Estos líderes han llevado a cabo una gran hazaña
en Afganistán.
Han incrementado activamente el acceso a la asistencia médica
para la mayoría de la población.
Están mejorando el estatus sanitario
de la población afgana,
que solía ser el peor del mundo.
De hecho, el Ministro de Salud afgano hace cosas
que ojalá hiciéramos en EE. UU.
Usan, por ejemplo, datos para elaborar políticas.
Es increíble.
(Risas)
La otra preocupación que se oye mucho es
"Simplemente no podemos pagarlo; no tenemos el dinero.
Es insostenible".
Les informo que la situación actual
y el sistema que tenemos actualmente
es el más caro e ineficiente que uno pueda imaginar.
La situación actual es que cuando gobiernos como el de EE. UU.
o, digamos, el conjunto de gobiernos
que integran la Comisión Europea,
gastan 15 mil millones de dólares cada año
en asistencia humanitaria, de emergencia y en casos de catástrofe en todo el mundo.
Eso no es asistencia externa, simplemente auxilio ante catástrofes.
El 95 % se destina a agencias de asistencia internacional,
que luego deben importar recursos a estas zonas,
y desarrollar algún tipo de, digamos, sistema sanitario provisorio,
que luego desmantelan cuando se quedan sin dinero.
Por tanto, nuestro trabajo es evidente.
Para nosotros, como expertos en políticas comunitarias de salud a nivel mundial,
nuestro primer trabajo es volvernos expertos en cómo observar
las fortalezas y debilidades
de los sistemas de salud en situaciones de amenaza.
Y ahí es cuando vemos a los médicos huir
cuando vemos que los recursos se agotan,
que las instituciones se desmoronan --
esa es la urgencia.
Ahí es cuando debemos sonar la alarma y sacudir los brazos.
¿De acuerdo?
Ahora no.
Todos pueden ver que es urgente, no necesitan que les digamos.
Número dos:
los lugares como Harvard, donde trabajo, deben seguir el ejemplo
de la experiencia del BM en Afganistán,
y debemos -- y lo haremos --
construir bases sólidas para apoyar a los líderes de los sectores de salud.
Estas personas arriesgan sus vidas.
Creo que podemos emular su valor al brindar apoyo.
Número tres:
debemos establecer nuevas asociaciones de colaboración.
En nuestro centro mundial de la salud,
hemos lanzado una iniciativa con la OTAN y otros responsables de la seguridad
para explorar qué pueden hacer ellos para proteger a las instituciones de salud
durante su despliegue.
Queremos que vean
que proteger a los sistemas de salud y otras instituciones sociales esenciales
es una parte fundamental de su misión.
No se trata simplemente de evitar el daño colateral;
se trata de alcanzar la paz.
Pero los socios más importantes a los que debemos captar son Uds.,
el público estadounidense, y por supuesto el público mundial.
Porque a menos que comprendan el valor de las instituciones sociales,
como los sistemas de salud en contextos delicados,
nunca apoyarán las iniciativas para salvarlos.
Nunca harán clic en ese artículo
que dice "Miren, en tal país todos esos médicos están huyendo.
¿Qué querrá decir?
¿Qué significará
en cuanto a la habilidad de esos sistemas de salud para detectar la gripe?"
"Mmm, probablemente no sea bueno". Eso es lo que les diría.
En la pantalla
pueden ver a mis tres defensores y creadores de instituciones favoritos.
Aquí tenemos a George C. Marshall,
él fue quien propuso el Plan Marshall
para salvar, tras la 2ª Guerra Mundial, a las instituciones económicas europeas.
Y esta es Eleanor Roosevelt.
Su labor en materia de derechos humanos realmente sirve de cimiento
para toda organización internacional de derechos humanos.
Mi gran favorito es Ben Franklin,
quien realizó mucho en cuanto a la creación de instituciones,
pero dio a luz a nuestra constitución.
Y les diré
que estas personas quienes, cuando nuestro país se veía amenazado,
o cuando el mundo se veía amenazado,
no dieron marcha atrás.
No hablaron de construir muros.
Hablaron de crear instituciones para proteger la seguridad humana,
para su generación y para la nuestra.
Y creo que nuestra generación debería hacer lo mismo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)